[Musik]
[Applaus]
hallo hallo ich ja kommen sie gehen ja
direkt so forsch los als es irgendwo
weil sie nicht ein problem sie sind von
der fdp
wenn ich dich reinigung hatten aber sie
sind gar nicht christian lindner nein
wir sind ja auch mehr als nur christen
schon sind wir eine enthüllungs format
die fdp hat noch mehr leute als
christian lindner
wusstet ihr dass was wollen sie denn
trinken hamse nada eppler
wir haben auch bier ist ja fußball dabei
hätte bier hat er sogar so viel prozent
gehabt ungefähr wie die fdp 2013
ein anständiges leben wir wohnen noch
daheim ja gott ich hatte schon gedacht
wir hätten vielleicht die eingebunden
sind sie dann ausgezogen
ein wenig ausgezogen mit 16 mit 16
wusste gar nicht dass das so schnell
geht das ich als der uncoole dastehen
ich bin ja schon fußballerisch angezogen
die haben vorsprung richtig ja ich hatte
noch versucht irgendwie passenden
trikots vorzubereiten irgendwie aber ich
habe so schnell kein trikot von den
caymans gefunden also hier sind einige
dabei die gingen ich hätte sonst auch
noch passt auch zu öffnen und schweizer
wobei ich habe ja was mitgebracht
nachdem die deutschlands leider raus
sind nehme ich meine mannschaft von
eintracht frankfurt noch spielern
drücken wollen so gruber kommt ins
wohnzimmer
jetzt aber nicht gerade mit ok was
soll's nie verkehrt hat rainer brüderle
nicht so oft gesagt dann sagt sodann
lesen sie sind mit 18 denn die junge
liberale eingetreten richtig ich habe
mich damals erkundigt weil meine erste
wahlentscheidung bei der bundestagswahl
bevorstehen
dann habe ich mich bei den
jugendorganisationen umgeguckt wirklich
bei allen und da habe ich das wieder
gefunden was bei uns zu hause gelebt
wurde nämlich freiheit und verantwortung
und das habe ich bei den julis wieder
gefunden und waren einfach coole typen
also von daten das hat für mich ein
bisschen raus gebracht also wer war
wirklich gut
mit 18 direkt in die jungen lieben also
kann man sagen geld war ihre erste liebe
geld fand ich meine erste liebe meine
erste liebe verrat ich jetzt den namen
nicht aber wie für christian mit
vornamen einer hoffentlich trifft damit
vornamen brauchen definitiv anderer typ
also war bisschen rafinha als der gut
ein bisschen rostig jetzt brauche ich
anschließend versucht man das ist klar
ich hoffe sind präpariert
ich bin noch da achtung zuschauer war
das heißt sie sind mal ungebunden ich
bin tatsächlich gebunden aber ich dachte
für die kamera kann ich so liebe
zuschauer
liebe freundinnen das war jetzt noch war
nur fake war wirklich nur fällt wirklich
man sieht dass die ganze zeit halten
ansonsten kann man dazwischen und steine
könnten ausgesprochen
jetzt ist nicht mehr das einzige was
zwischen uns stehen schmeckt sind ja
also daran kann man wenig falsch machen
wir mit die typische aufmacht danke ich
kenne das in jungs zu machen dass das
dann auch mal so eine ecke ein paar
wochen über dauert dann hat der
frischegrad doch gelitten
die fdp hat auch überdauert und aber ich
habe extra noch was für sie vorbereitet
dass sie sich hier richtig heimisch
fühlen den habe ich heute schon gesehen
aber da hängt bei mir nicht überm bett
da habe ich andere foto persischen wen
haben sie über betting familienfotos ach
so mein mann sammelt schafe ja nicht als
fotos sondern eher als stofftier okay
das ist ja wirklich gerade
regierungskrise
daher wollte ich eigentlich machen wir
sind ja ein comedy format darum auch mal
ein gag frage stellen kann die fdp
irgendwas tun
wir haben entsprechende konzepte auch
für die flüchtlings- und
zuwanderungspolitik vorgelegt und man
müsste eigentlich nur eine lesefähigkeit
haben
das wäre eins zu eins umsetzbar also von
daher merkt man es geht ganz ohne dass
lothar klein kriegen wollen
vielleicht wird horst seehofer ab los
und ja je nachdem entweder er oder
merkel weil sie liegen vielleicht bei 17
[Gelächter]
na ja also ich finds halt eher traurig
dass wir eine große koalition haben die
gerade die regierung handlungsunfähig
macht klar und wie es zu dieser großen
koalition gekommen wäre hätte das
verhindern können
das ist so schade dass es niemanden gab
er es hätte tun können also ich nehme
jetzt 11 dass sie offensichtlich
bedauern dass die freien demokraten mich
in der regierung sind leider nicht mutig
gesprächspartner gefunden auch gerade
bei der christdemokratin
was glauben sie wer wird weltmeister ich
habe auch kein problem damit wenn andere
sich durchsetzt ich kenne das gefühl
david gegen goliath das hat immer meine
sympathie wegen der fdp verliert da wird
also sind grundsätzlich in der in der
situation ein bisschen anspruchsvollere
botschaft hat überzeugen zu müssen
ich dachte mir schon dass wir so viel
spaß zusammen haben
schrecklicher überlegt jetzt ob die fdp
vielleicht doch überzeugend
[Gelächter]
stellen wir uns mal ganz neutral ihn ja
wetter ein bisschen auch ein 2 das sieht
gut aus oder perfekt sind sie überrascht
das habe ich ihnen schon so getraut also
ich meine kollegen ich haben sie auch
hunger ja ja klar
gerade auf würstchen so habe aber immer
essen und welche er die dicken und
dünnen je nach tagesform
wie sieht das bei ihnen aus ich liebe
die dünnen ehrlich gesagt die sind
meistens irgendwie größer
sie wissen sowie ist wie ich die youtube
zuschauer kennen wir werden wieder
irgendwas schmutziges wieder raus machen
das risiko das man eingehen bevor wir
essen gerne da wird er ohne catcher
gerne immer drauf und essen sie das soll
beweist denn fdp hilft doch leuten die
unternehmer gehaltsklasse die macht wir
sind service opposition im deutschen
bundestag noch nicht mitgekriegt
wir wissen nicht für wen aber es ist ein
tor gefallen
als hat leute glücklich gemacht oder
vielleicht gucken wie sich gerade noch
mal den wahlabend kommt 2013 ja die ente
bis raus haben wir zum torjubel
deshalb können wir doch eigentlich nicht
ändern perfekte stoiber an interner
mittag danke danke dass sie hier waren
[Musik]